[Musik]
Europa war schon immer eine unruhiger
Kontinent denkt an die vielen Völker die
hier leben an die Katalanen in Spanien
an die ihren auf den britischen Inseln
oder die Ungarn in Rumänien da gibt es
einige die eigenständig sein wollen oder
gar unabhängig und ihren eigenen
startgründen die Region mit den
stärksten ethnischen Spannungen ist
jedoch der Balkan hier spielen die
Konflikte teilweise seit Jahrhunderten
in den 1990er Jahren erlebt Europa einen
Shop da glaubte man endlich die Teilung
des Kalten Krieges überwunden zu haben
aber auf dem Balkan grad ein Bürgerkrieg
aus während Deutschland
das einzige Jugoslawien in blutigen
Kriegen vor einiger Zeit haben wir hier
auf visualpolitik schon einmal über die
Konflikte und die Geschichte des Balkans
berichtet die entsprechenden Videos habe
ich euch in der Beschreibung verlinkt
schon darin haben wir auch einen
schwingenden Konflikten gewesen der sich
jetzt tatsächlich noch einmal verschärft
hat die Rede ist vom neuen Säbelrasseln
an der Grenze zwischen Serbien und dem
Kosovo Kosovo ist die Region die Serien
seit langem als ab einige Provinz
betrachtet
Kosovo feiert 15 Jahre Unabhängigkeit
die Republik Kosovo erklärte 2008 ihre
Unabhängigkeit aber Serbien blockt
weiterhin die internationale Anerkennung
der Autonomie des Landes mit
Unterstützung Chinas und Russlands die
Lage ist wie folgt beide Länder
entstanden in ihrer heutigen Form im
Zuge des jugoslawischen Bürgerkriegs
dieser endete 1999 nachdem die NATO mit
Luftangriffen gegen Serbien interveniert
hatte Präsident Serbiens war damals
Slobodan Milosevic er endete nach der
Befriedung durch die NATO in einem
Gefängnis im niederländischen Den Haag
der Internationale Strafgerichtshof für
das ehemalige Jugoslawien hatte ihn
wegen Kriegsverbrechen angeklagt
tatsache ist jedoch dass der Krieg zwar
zu Ende ging der zugrunde liegende
ethnische politische Konflikt aber
ungelöst blieb und genau zu sein dauert
der Konflikt bis zum heutigen Tage an
der Krieg im Kosovo war der letzte in
der langen Reihe von Kriegen auf dem
Gebiet des ehemaligen Jugoslawiens er
endete mit dem Vertrag von Kumanovo
dieser sah zur Befriedigung des Gebiets
die Entsendung internationaler Truppen
vor was dieser Vertrag allerdings nicht
enthielt war eine Garantie der
Unabhängigkeit des Kosovo offiziell
gehört also der Kosovo noch zu dem Land
das heute Serbien heißt trotzdem
erklärten die kosovarischen schließlich
einseitig ihre Unabhängigkeit die
Gründung der Republik Kosovo erfolgte
nur wenige Jahre später im Jahr 2008 und
seitdem sind die Beziehungen zwischen
Serbien und den Kosovo kälter als eine
russische Winter natürlich wird die
Republik Kosovo von Serbien nicht
anerkannt Serbien beansprucht weiterhin
über das Gebiet auch internationale ist
erfolgreiche Status umstritten doch zu
Belgrad Pech wird das Kosovo von rund
100 Mitgliedstaaten der Vereinten
Nationen anerkannt
[Musik]
darunter auch von den USA und von 22 der
27 Staaten der Europäische Union in der
Praxis bedeutet dies dass eine Großteil
der entwickelten Welt und die Mehrheit
der westlichen Welt die kleine Republik
als zu drehen statt betrachtet Serbien
dürfte es also schwer haben gegen die
Unabhängigkeit des Kosovo vorzugehen
[Musik]
dennoch hat Belgrad noch lange nicht
aufgegeben es wird tatsächlich den
Kosovo zurückgewinnen jedes Mal wenn die
Kosovaren irgendeine Maßnahme in
Richtung Loslösung von Serbien
ankündigen Flammen die Spannungen wieder
auf besonders heftig geht es in der hier
abgebildeten Region zu obwohl im Kosovo
insgesamt überwiegend Albaner Leben
besteht dieses Teilstück aus vier
Gemeinden in den Serben in der Mehrheit
sind genannt Nord die dortige Mehrheit
will praktisch nichts mit dem Kosovo zu
tun haben die Einwohner wollen ein Teil
Serbien sein und wie reagiert die
serbische Regierung auf diesen Wunsch
nun sie hat sich zum Beschützer aller
ethnischen Serben erklärt und besonders
derjenigen die im Kosovo Leben und da
die Kosovo Albaner die Unabhängigkeit
der Kosovo Serben genauso wenig
akzeptieren wie ihre von den Serben
akzeptiert wird ist der Konflikt
vorprogrammiert wenn Sie denken dass die
Kosovo Albaner kommen werden um
Verordnung im Norden des Landes zu
sorgen wozu sie im übrigen kein Recht
haben wieder nach Abkommen noch nach dem
Willen des Volkes ganz fürchte ich dass
das zu einer Katastrophe führen wird
Alexander Präsident Serbiens Ende 2022
und Anfang 2023 flammten die alten
Spannungen wieder auf die Kosovo Serben
hatten Straßenblockaden errichtet
Serbien seine Truppen in Alam
Bereitschaft versetzt für viele
Analysten sind das Vorzeichen einer
künftigen Katastrophe es ist die Rede
davon das mitten in Europa ein weiterer
Krieg ausbrechen könnte aber ist es
wirklich denkbar dass zwischen diesen
beiden Ländern wieder die Waffen
sprechen ich meine ist haben hätten ist
ja ziemlich schnell mit der NATO als
Gegner zu tun oder doch nicht nun lasst
uns hier mal lieber genauer nachsehen
und alles wegen ein paar
Nummernschildern
[Musik]
könnt ihr euch denken was die größten
politischen militärischen Spannungen
seit Jahren zwischen den Serben und dem
Kosovaren ausgelöst hat nun nichts
anderes als der Wechsel von
Kfz-Kennzeichen bringen
alles begann im Juli 2022 die
kosovarische Regierung unter Albin Kurti
kündigte eine Änderung an es sollte
keine alten serbischen
Fahrzeugzulassungen mehr in Kosovo geben
sondern alles serbische Schilder sollten
auf Kosovo Nummernschilder umgestellt
werden der Plan von kurtisar folgendes
vor wer nach einer gewissen Zeit noch
mit serbischen Schild durch die Gegend
fuhr der sollte zunächst verwandt werden
in Phase 2 wäre es zu strafen gekommen
und in Phase 3 hätte jedem ein
Fahrverbot oder die beschlagnahmen des
Autos gedroht wenn er oder sie bis dahin
noch kein neues kosovarisches
Nummernschild gehabt hätte außerdem
kündigte die kosovarische Regierung
anders serbische Staatsbürger bei der
Einreise in den Kosovo spezielle
Dokumente mit sich führen müssen
das kann bei den serbischen Kosovaren im
Norden des Kosovo überhaupt nicht gut an
für viele Menschen weiß gleichbedeutend
mit dem Status eines Bürgers zweiter
Klasse
sie meinten dass ihnen mit all dem nur
das Leben schwer gemacht werden sollte
die Sache mit den Nummernschildern hat
dies der beständige Bevölkerung wirklich
empört sie sollten ja jetzt
Nummernschilder eines Staates verwenden
geben Sie sich nicht zugehörig fühlten
den sie nicht als ihre Autorität ansahen
und ja es mag euch vielleicht wie eine
Überreaktion vorkommen aber ich
versichere euch dass die nationale
Identität in diesem Gegenden extrem
ernst genommen wird so ernst das
vermeintlich banale Dinge wie dieser
verwaltungsaktion hervorruft
und so war es auch diesmal als Reaktion
errichteten serbische kosovarische
Gruppen im Juli 2022 Straßenbarrikaden
im nordkor Kosovo sie wollten jeglichen
Anordnungen kosovarischer Behörden nicht
mehr voll gelassen die Spannung steht so
stark an dass die eingreifen musste
carvor steht für Kosovo Force und ist
eine multinationale Truppe im Kosovo
unter Leitung der NATO sie besteht seit
dem Ende des Bürgerkriegs diese
kameraeinheiten wurden nun verlegt um
auf den Straßen zu kontrollieren und die
Sicherheit zu gewährleisten während die
kosovarische Polizei die Grenzen
kurz gesagt wegen ein paar
Nummernschildern und ein paar Papieren
gegen das Chaos wieder los die Situation
ist also beileibe nicht einfach und egal
was man von der Unabhängigkeit des
Kosovo hält kann man die Wut dieser
Menschen durchaus verstehen immerhin
haben sie schon seit Generationen in
dieser Region gelebt und fühlen sich nun
mal nicht als Teil des neuen Staates der
ihnen aufgezwängt wurde auf der anderen
Seite muss man auch die albanische
Mehrheit im Kosovo verstehen die sich
nun mal nicht als Serben ansehen sondern
einen eigenen Staat wollen
[Musik]
der riesen Ärger wegen neuer
zulassungsregeln für Autos und neuer
passvorschriften war also durchaus
vorhersehbar und es folgte ein
langwieriges hin und her man hatte sich
gestritten geeinigt und wieder
gestritten und es fehlte auch nicht an
Appellen zur Mäßigung seitens der EU und
der Vereinigten Staaten im November 2022
sagte die kosovarische Regierung noch
dass die Umstellung der Nummernschilder
abgeschlossen sei und dass der
Stufenplan zwischen November 2022 und
April 2023 umgesetzt werden würde tja
und dann kam es hierzu
Posen setzen massenaustritte aus
staatlichen Institutionen fort die
Kosovo serbischen Polizeibeamten die am
Wochenende zusammen mit Abgeordnete
Bürgermeister und Justizbeamten ihren
diskutierten haben ihren Rückzug
fortgesetzt und ihre Waffen und
Handschellen abgegeben natürlich sind
diese Ereignisse in Serbien nicht
unbemerkt geblieben und man hat die
Gelegenheit genutzt sich an die Seite
der Streitenden Beamten zu stellen seht
euch an was Belgrad gemacht hat
Serbien sagt und ich sage das auch wir
werden uns um die zurückgetreten Beamten
kümmern das kostet wieder 50 oder 60
million en Euro aber wir werden das
alles machen Alexis Präsident die Serben
haben sie einfach als ihre Beamte
anerkannt mit einem Mal hatte Serien
also wieder Staatsbeamte im Kosovo und
in den darauf folgenden Wochen wurden
die Dinge nur noch schlimmer
nachdem die ethnischen Serben begannen
aus den staatlichen Institutionen des
Kosovo auszutreten kam es bei zu
Konflikten auf der Straße der
streitliegende Nummernschilder wurde
auch Vermittlung der EU zwar Ende
November 2020 offiziell beigelegt doch
die Gemüter waren zu erhitzt als dass
der Konflikt damit geendet hätte
blockieren Straße zu den wichtigsten
Grenzübergängen im unruhigen Norden sie
waren empört über die Verhaftung eines
ehemaligen serbischen Polizeibeamten der
verdächtigt wird an den jüngsten
Angriffen auf Polizisten im Kosovo
beteiligt gewesen zu sein im Dezember 22
versetzten die Serben ihre Armee in
Alarmbereitschaft also in die
bereitschaftsstufe vor einem Krieg die
Lage sah echt brenzlig aus aber bis dann
ist der Krieg nicht ausgebrochen zum
Glück aber bestätigen wirklich das
Risiko das ist in Europa zu einem
weiteren Krieg kommt könnte es dazu
kommen dass Serbien den Kosovo angreift
nun lasst uns das gleich herausfinden
nach einem wichtigen Hinweis unsere
Sponsors in KODi wisst ihr eigentlich
was data Broker sind also datenmakler
das sind Unternehmen die überall
persönliche Daten über uns aus
Kartoffeln und einsammeln zum Beispiel
aus öffentlich zugänglichen Datenbanken
aus unserem serverhalten eine Netze oder
wenn man mal dummerweise an einem
Gewinnspiel teilgenommen hat sie sammeln
und verknüpfen diese Daten um sie dann
auszuwerten und an andere Unternehmen zu
verkaufen das können dann seriöse Firmen
sein oder aber auch Betrüger die uns mit
unerwünschten Anrufen SMS und E-Mails
bombardieren oder gar ausnehmen wollen
das Problem ist niemand von uns kann
wissen an wen die data Broker unsere
Daten verkaufen wir haben 0 Kontrolle
darüber was wir aber tun können ist sie
zu kontaktieren und sie aufzufordern
unsere Daten bei sich zu löschen denn
dazu sind Sie gesetzlich verpflichtet
dabei stoßen wir doch auf ein weiteres
Problem es gibt tausende dieser data
Broker und sie alle wollen auf
unterschiedliche weiße kontaktiert
werden und manchmal leben sie die
Anfrage einfach ab und man muss sich
dann überlegen wie man damit umgeht kurz
um es ist eine süße Fußarbeit und wäre
es nicht toll das Ganze zu
automatisieren quasi als Dienstleistung
ja jetzt kommt die gute Nachricht diese
Dienstleistung gibt es bereits uns
handelt sich um keinen geringeren als
den Sponsor dieses Videos inkognit du
meldest dich einfach bei in Kombi an und
beauftragt sie in deinem Namen bei den
data Brokern aufzuräumen und schon
geht's los auf einem übersichtlichen
Dashboard kannst du sehen bei welchen
data Brokern sie deine Daten gefunden
haben wie sie Kontakt mit Ihnen
aufnehmen und wieder Fortschritt der
Löschanträge ist und dann bekommst du
E-Mails von diesen Unternehmen in denen
steht wir haben Ihre Daten gelöscht na
ist das nicht eine Wohltat die traurige
Wahrheit unserer Welt ist nun mal wenn
man diese Löschanträge manuell stellen
wollte würde diesen Monate dauern etwas
was kein normaler Mensch auf sich nehmen
würde also haben sich alle einfach damit
abgefunden dass Ihre Daten draußen
herumgeistern und missbraucht werden tja
bis jetzt schaut euch also bitte
unbedingt das Angebot von ihm über den
Link in der Beschreibung zu diesem Video
an dort findest du auch den Promo Code
politik.de und wenn du zu den ersten 100
gehörst die nutzen gibt dir inkognit 20
% Rabatt ist doch echt nicht wahr und
falls Ihr uns etwas Nettes tun wollt
ebenfalls in der Beschreibung unter
diesem Video findet ihr einen Spenden
Link mit dem was helfen könnte dieses
Projekt zu finanzieren so und nun lass
uns wieder schnell auf den Balkan
zurückkehren um die dortige Kriegsgefahr
auszuloten
der nächste Krieg in Europa
der Krieg in der Ukraine hat ganz Europa
plötzlich aus einem süßen Traum geweckt
dem Traum vom ewigen Frieden auf dem
alten Kontinent spätestens jetzt hat
sich diese Stimmung natürlich verändert
neben der Ukraine ist der Balkan
wahrscheinlich der anderen große
geopolitische Brennpunkt in Europa vor
allem der Westbahn aber besteht
unmittelbare Kriegsgefahr nun in die
Zukunft sehen können wir auch nicht aber
wir können beurteilen ob die
Voraussetzungen für einen Krieg gegeben
sind und hier steht schon mal fest dass
Serbien bereits seit vielen Jahren
erheblich in seinen Militär investiert
hat im Jahr 2018 waren die
Verteidigungsausgaben fast doppelt so
hoch wie noch drei Jahre zuvor und im
Jahr 2022 investierte die Regierung und
eine Milliarde Euro allein in neue
Ausrüstung ja okay eine Milliarde klingt
nicht nach besonders viel vor allem in
Antrag dessen dass der Kosovo weiterhin
vor Wahl unter dem Schutz der NATO steht
aber der Trend der letzten Jahre ist
schon ziemlich auffällig
Serbien ist auf einer
einkaufs-zwischen 2015 und 2021 sind die
fertigungsausgaben Serbiens um rund 70
Prozent auf 1,4 Milliarden US-Dollar pro
Jahr gestiegen Russland und Weißrussland
haben dem Land 1020 Jets geschenkt
russland hat Serbien 30 Panzer und
gepanzerte mannschaftsansporter
geschenkt und ein Luftabwehrsystem
verkauft deshalb chinesische gepanzerte
Drohnen russische Hubschrauber und ein
französisches Bodenluft Raketensystem
gekauft und mehr ethnische Spannungen
sind schon eine gefährliche Mixtur und
Meldungen wie die folgende können leicht
für Aufruhr sorgen
Kosovo Soldat außer Dienste wird
verdächtigt zwei Einheimische Serben
verbunden zu haben die Polizei sagte
dass beide Opfer im Alter von 11 und 21
Jahren ins Krankenhaus gebracht wurden
und ihre Verletzungen nicht
lebensbedrohlich waren die Polizei gab
an der Verdächtige seit 33 Jahre alt für
das aber gleich zum Krieg in null Komma
nichts von der Kneipenschlägerei zum
Kanonen Donnerstag nun so schnell geht's
dann doch nicht das zumindest meinen wir
es ist eher unwahrscheinlich dass
Serbien und der Kosovo zum Schauplatz
eines neuen Krieges in Europa werden
[Musik]
zumindest in absehbarer Zeit aber warum
schätzen wir die Lage der Erde ein und
dafür gibt es mehrere Gründe der erste
ist offensichtlich die Präsenz der eng
mit der NATO verbundenen
Jahren 1999 sind und 4000 NATO bzw
carporttruppen im Kosovo stationiert das
sind Soldaten Anwesenheit allein dazu
dient jeden groß angelegten serbischen
Angriff abzuschreiben
denn natürlich würden bei einem
Invasionsversuch am Ende nicht nur der
Kosovo sondern auch die NATO-Truppen
angegriffen werden und ein solcher
Angriff könnte für Serbien enorm teuer
werden glaub mir niemand in Belgrad will
zurück zu einer Situation wie damals im
Kosovo kriegt achtet mal auf diese
Schlagzeilen Zehnter dezember 2022
Serbien bitte die NATO serbischen
Militär und Polizei im Kosovo einsetzen
zu dürfen
29 dezember 2022 Alexander Vucic hebt
den Alarmzustand für die serbischen
Streitkräfte auf 8 Januar 2023 die NATO
Linz ersuchen ab seine Truppen im Kosovo
einzusetzen denk mal einen Moment
darüber nach wäre es nicht seltsam die
NATO um Erlaubnis zu bitten serbische
Streitkräfte in einem Gebiet zu
stationieren dass man als ein eigenes
betrachtet würde man hier extra noch
höflich fragen wenn man wirklich
vorhatte dort einzumarschieren aus
serbischer Sicht gehört das Territorium
des Kosovo genauso zu Serbien wie
Belgrad selbst
[Musik]
aber wie ihr gesehen habt hat Serbien
die NATO um Erlaubnis gebeten seine
Streitkräfte dort zu stationieren und
das Nein der NATO haben Sie denn auch
akzeptiert das spricht nicht gerade für
akute Kriegsgefahr es spricht eher dafür
dass die Serben erkennen wer hier
wirklich das Sagen hat es ist also
äußerst unwahrscheinlich dass die Serben
auch nur daran denken die NATO mit
militärischen Übergriffen auf dem Kosovo
zu verärgern das ist aber nicht das
einzige Argument das stark gegen eine
serbische Invasion spricht vor nicht
allzu langer Zeit haben wir euch auch
visualpolitik von der besonderen
Beziehung zwischen Serbien oder
Europäischen Union erzielt falls ihr das
Video noch nicht gesehen habt findet ihr
den Link in der Beschreibung kurz gesagt
Serbien ist eine der sieben Staaten die
den offiziellen Status eines Kandidaten
für die Vollmitgliedschaft in der EU
haben dies haben haben zwei Jahre lang
kaum die nötigen Reformen durchgeführt
die einen Beitritt ermöglichen würden
aber der Kandidaten Status liegt quasi
auf dem Tisch und allein dieser bringt
schon erhebliche Vorteile mit sich
schon durch den Kandidatenstatus genießt
das Land erhebliche handelsurteile und
bekommt auch Wirtschaftshilfe außerdem
ist die serbische Wirtschaft schon jetzt
eng mit der EU verflochten mehr als 60
Prozent der Exporte und fast genauso
viel Prozent der Importe der serbischen
Wirtschaft sind für die Europäische
Union bestimmt oder stammen aus ihr und
nicht nur das 60 bis 80% aller
ausländischen Direktinvestitionen die
ihr seit 2010 in Serbien gibt stammen
aus der EU und warum erzählen wir euch
das nun erinnert ihr euch was ihr zu
Beginn des Videos gesagt haben also dass
die mehr der europäischen Staaten den
Kosovo als unabhängig anerkennt also das
ist der entscheidende Punkt wenn Serbien
im Umgang mit dem Kosovo über das Ziel
hinausschießt wäre sein Status als
EU-Beitrittskandidat gefährdet oder
sogar aufgehoben und dann wäre es auch
vorbei mit all den Vorteilen die dieser
Status mit sich bringt
sagt dass die Kosovo Gespräche
fortgesetzt werden müssen damit man auf
dem Weg in die EU bleibt die
EU-Mitgliedschaft ist für uns von
vitalem Interesse ohne Verbündete kann
man nicht funktionieren sagte wirklich
auf einer Sondersitzung des Parlaments
natürlich würde es im Falle eines
Angriffs garantiert internationale
Sanktion gegen Serbien geben genauso wie
ist Russland passiert ist und das wäre
für ein Land das wirtschaftlich dermaßen
abhängig von der Europäischen Union ist
absolut verheiratet
Präsident Alexander
Kosovo vor internationaler Isolation
serbiendol international isolation und
wirtschaftlicher Niedergang wenn es
einen neuen westlichen Plan zur
Normalisierung der Beziehung zu seinem
ehemaligen kriegsverein Kosovo ablehnt
das sagte der Präsident des Balkan
Landes Alex am Montag und nicht damit
offenbar von seiner bisherigen harten
Rhetorik ab um fair zu sein die
Europäische Union ist der größte
Investor in Serbien sagte er wir müssen
die Dinge auf faire und objektive Weise
betrachten Serbien erhielt diese Warnung
letzte Woche während des Besuchs einer
Gruppe Amerikaner schon europäischer
gesamter die ihre Bemühungen verstärkt
haben die langjährigen Spannungen in der
unbeständigen wahlkarregion angesichts
des russischen Einmarsches in der
Ukraine zu entschärfen die entschlossen
hat das bestens bei den derzeitigen
Russland Sanktion ist ein wichtiges
Signal an die Welt und besonders an jene
autokratischen Herrscher dort draußen
die über militärische Abenteuer
nachdenken aber Spinde den Faden
trotzdem mal weiter könnte es Serbien
den Krieg denn noch wagen weil es
vielleicht einen starken Verbündeten in
Rücken hat nein auch das fällt praktisch
aus das einzige Land das Serien immer
Beistand war ausgerechnet Russland aber
wie ihr wisst scheitert dieses gerade
phänomenal an einer dreitägigen
spezialoperation die Hosen sind
militärisch wirtschaftlich und
diplomatisch dermaßen zermürbt dass sie
Serbien einfach nicht helfen können und
diese Einsicht ist auf Seiten der Serben
offenbar angekommen Alexander Gutschein
hat Anfang Februar 2023 plötzlich sehr
persönliche Töne Richtung Kosovo
angeschlagen
verurteilen die russische Aggression und
respektieren die territoriale Integrität
Kiews der serbische Präsident Alexander
butschitsch und wer scheidende
tschechische Präsidenten läuft der Mann
hielten heute eine gemeinsame
Pressekonferenz in Belgrad ab auf der
Sie die russische Aggression gegen die
Ukraine Verurteilten und erklärten dass
sie die territoriale Integrität der
Ukraine respektieren das geschah wohl
auch aufgrund eines Gesprächs mit dem
US-Außenminister Anthony blinken denn in
den USA hat man auf gut deutsch gesagt
ich Schnauze allmählich voll vom ewigen
Konflikt auf dem Balkan parallel hat die
EU auf ihrem Beitrittskandidaten Druck
aufgebaut Deutschland und Frankreich
haben einen Plan vorgelegt wonach
Serbien und Kosovo sich zwar nicht als
legitim anerkennen müssen aber doch
wenigstens eine friedliche Koexistenz
akzeptieren sollten
rutschig zeitenwände oder spielaufzeit
viele interpretierten Budget Schritt vor
schnell als Abkehr von Moskau und
Hinwendung zum Westen unabhängig davon
ob wirklich in die letztendlich an dem
ablehnt ist dies das erste Mal seit 2012
an die Macht kam dass er tatsächlich in
die Enge getrieben wurde allerdings
dafür das Gute sich vorsichtig offen für
die Pläne der EU zeigte wurde er dann
pront im Parlament als Verräter
beschimpft die interne Lage bleibt also
weiterhin regeln
fünf Männer mit Verbindungen zur
wagnergruppe nach Kosovo Protesten
verhaftet die serbische Polizei hat fünf
Männer verhaftet die im Verdacht stehen
am Vortag bei einer Demonstration zum
gewaltsamen Sturz des Präsidenten
Alexander wutschisch aufgerufen zu haben
die Verhafteten Männer von denen einige
mutmaßlich Verbindungen zur privaten
russischen militärgruppe Wagner haben
Namen am Mittwochabend an einer
Demonstration rechtsextremer pro
russischer gruppenteil die forderten
dass der populistische Präsident Alex
einen westlichen Plan zur Normalisierung
der Beziehung zu Serbiens abtrünniger
Provinz Kosovo ablehnt wie ihr seht
rodelt es auf dem Balkan aber einen
Krieg kann sich Serbien einfach nicht
leisten er sieht deshalb nicht so aus
als würden dein absehbarer Zeit die
Waffen sprechen aber jetzt seid ihr an
der Reihe glaubt ihr dass zwischen den
Kosovo und Serbien in Zukunft wieder ein
Krieg ausbrechen könnte was denkt ihr
wie die internationale Gemeinschaft in
einem solchen Fall reagieren würde habt
ihr eine Idee wie man den Konflikt lösen
könnte wie immer sind auf eure
Diskussion zu diesem Thema schon mächtig
gespannt ich hoffe dass euch dieses
Video gefallen hat und ihr vielleicht
auch etwas dabei gelernt habt falls ja
gibt uns bitte ein Leid dass man
vergessliches Abo mit Glück und keines
unserer Videos mehr zu verpassen
natürlich freuen uns auch jederzeit über
eine Spende von euch dieses Projekt
weiterzuführen den Link dazu findet ihr
in der Beschreibung unter dem Video
macht's gut bis bald
[Musik]